NIKOLAI: Only the sky's the
limit in the virtual world
as we build.
But when you start moving
around in the physical world
at the same time, you
first have to think
about how to make the
virtual and physical coexist.
In the Designing for
Physical Boundaries episode
we saw how physical limits can
impact the augmented reality
you are in, and how they can
prevent you from going places
in the virtual experience.
My name is Nikolai,
and in this episode
I'm going to show you
how to deal with size
limits in the virtual world.
When you are building augmented
reality experiences that
allow the users to
move around, you also
have to think about the size of
the virtual experience you're
building.
If your world is
very small, the user
may accidentally walk out of it.
As a developer, when
the virtual world
is smaller than
the physical world,
you've got a
challenge to make sure
that the users stay within it.
That is you need to handle
the virtual boundaries.
For example, if you
create an icy world
with a single and small ice
flow for your uses penguin,
an immediate issue is that
it's tempting for the user
to jump off of it.
Since the virtual
world is smaller
than their physical
room, what do you
want to happen when they cross
the limit of the virtual world?
There is a simple technique that
keeps the user on the ice flow.
Let the ice follow the user.
You can accomplish this by
putting an invisible wall
around the virtual world.
When the user runs into that
bounding box and keeps going,
they move the wall and the
whole world ahead of them.
It is also possible to
make virtual objects appear
solid to the user by adding
colliders around them.
Pushing against the collider
will also move the whole world.
However, if the collider
is placed poorly,
it can make parts of the virtual
world become inaccessible.
If the user walks into
a solid rock on the ice,
they will effectively
push it in front of them.
While a solid object can cause
places to become inaccessible,
it does prevent the user from
walking straight through it,
which is neither natural
nor great if the object is
large and hollow.
The user may then
get lost inside it,
and you must make sure that they
can find their way out of it
again.
If they continue to walk, they
may eventually push the rock
through a solid
physical obstacle,
such as a wall or a door.
If you are not careful about
aligning the virtual world
with the physical
world, your users
could be at risk of
inadvertently walking out
of the room or into
obstacles like walls.
So you should design
to minimize that.
Since the rock is not
pushed onto the other side
of the physical obstacle, it is
going to be hard for the users
to get to it in the future.
There are workarounds for this
situation such as the clutch
and teleportation modes.
We discuss these in the
Designing for Physical
Boundaries episode.
As an alternative
solution, you could instead
allow the user to
jump off the ice,
and gradually let them know that
they're exiting the experience.
In this example, we let the
physical world bleed through
as the user approaches the
boundary of the virtual.
It quite literally
informs the user
that they are leaving
the virtual space,
and entering reality again.
It also makes it really easy
for them to go back again.
They can simply turn
around and walk back
where they came from to return
to the virtual experience.
Finally, you could completely
eliminate all these issues
by procedurally extending
the size of the virtual world
to fit the physical surroundings
by using the depth sensor.
As a developer this
does entail more work,
but makes an experience
that works in more places.
In this example we
are adding blocks
as the user moves
beyond the limits
of the current populated zone.
In the penguin
game this same idea
could be used to automate
the generation of ice.
The user would then
never run out of places
to move to as their icy
world will be boundless.
It's not only the physical
world that constrains us.
The virtual world
can do that too.
You can put a fence
around the virtual world,
let the world follow the
user, or procedurally extend
the world as the
user moves around.
Somewhat easier to
implement, but harder to use.
And you have to consider
what's best for your situation.
There may also be other ways
to handle these edge cases,
and we'd love to hear
what you've come up with.
So visit our Google+ community,
and join us in our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.